[Music]
hi I'm Mike Seymour from FX guide.com
for wired looking at the tech of the
making of a new Disney film Maleficent
the film has a whole world of visual
effects but there's a second world of
detailed visual effects shots that until
now no one outside that filmmakers is
actually seen these completed shots are
made and then discarded just to try and
produce realistic digital characters for
the film matching fully digital
characters especially their faces is
extremely difficult in the film the
three main flower Pixies are
particularly difficult and challenging
as the audience gets to see them both as
their normal life size and then as their
smaller cuter pixie versions to make
these Pixies the director turn to face
experts and specialists Digital Domain
the normal approach is to film actors
faces on a motion capture stage and then
retarget those facial movements to the
digital puppet of the smaller pixie
which has of course different
proportions has less wrinkles
bigger eyes so if the side of the actors
mouth moves up for a smile then the
digital puppets mouth sides also move up
but doing this direct retargeting from
the actor straight through to the
digital character and one job makes it
extremely hard to work out what's going
wrong if something in the final clip
doesn't look right is the skin rock is
the expression inaccurate or was it just
simply that we didn't like the take that
the team had selected from the original
actress Digital Domain took a much
longer and more complex path to get from
the actress to the final but in so doing
it broke out each stage separately so
that each stage could be individually
tested the motion capture data was
coupled with light stage scanning now
thanks to hundreds of
computer-controlled LEDs this makes for
a very accurate model of the actress but
also gives us something called image
based lighting this allows one to view
the real actress under any lighting
configuration or really under any place
that you could record say natural light
the team then makes a completely digital
version of the actress textured and let
look exactly like the actress this test
for example places her in the production
officers boardroom only once they're
produced a perfect copy do they then
move on to animate this digital client
of the actress with every single line of
her dialogue from the film and don't
forget at this stage all of this
high-end animation and final rendering
will never be seen by anyone outside the
production especially not the audience
finally once the digital actress
performs and looks exactly like herself
they then discard all of this footage
and retarget back to the smaller pixie
version and then of course they rerender
it all over again the advantage of this
approach is that the director wants to
change for example the proportions of
the smaller pixie the team just has to
retarget and then re-render and I had a
second huge benefit of allowing one to
examine everything stage by stage as if
it was a final shot to hunt down
anything that maybe didn't look right
for example they could focus just on the
eyes or maybe focus just on how blood
flowed around the actresses face as she
talked this whole approach of producing
side by side animation may seem
incredibly expensive and time-consuming
but it's really what it takes to produce
a believable human face don't forget
subscribe for more behind the scenes
action I'm Mike Seymour for wide
you
[Music]